hallo mein name ist luca mir wird oft
vorgeworfen dass ich nur behinderte
spiele spiele deswegen spiele ich heute
mal call of duty black oder ich weiß gar
nicht ob das black ops es ist black ops
teil 2 sogar und wir spielen online was
viele eventuell nicht wissen ist das
jammern der elektronik ist in der esl
gespielt habe ich wurde dann erster im
japanese gaming contest worldwide
schittek ich habe das damals mal
gespielt ich war allerdings nie wirklich
gut ich habe mir so grob jetzt einmal
die steuerung beim dauerlauf doch und
ich werde
ich habe den nada fucking ersten kiel
gemacht was sagte jetzt ich scheiß
anderen blödmänner hier denke ich erst
mal eine schöne sämtlich an die auch
okay ich glaube irgendwann komplett
anderen weg als meine ganzen mitspieler
aber mal schauen ob ich irgendwie
der weg der in meinem team so mach call
of duty am meisten spaß einfach liegen
und sich das geschehen anschauen der typ
ist einfach polish wodka ok auf der
drohnen karte sieht man dass sie ihr
auch noch eine liste mit den hole ich
mir komm komm ich kriege ich komm her
komm her
kommt mir nicht an mit taktiken oder so
ich habe meine eigene taktik und die
gewinne dann blöd bist du kannst nicht
getötet ich in dieses auto irgendwie
rein
sorry ich habe nein nein das geht nicht
scheiß pizza und jetzt zerstörtes auto
da hinten
dieses spiel hat das beste versteck
aller zeiten
ich bin ein macher fucking bush ich kann
niemand da waren gegner der wahl wieder
aus motivieren wir eigentlich vor dem
wir haben 34 30 19 alter wir sind
richtig geil das team i love you all you
want to say to you marry me als cod
chefkoch view to you are my life ich
liebe dich chefkoch handy online auf
chefkoch.de kleiner die sache
ach ich komme damit nicht klar di luca
märkte einfach wenn den grünen nahmen
was ich darüber stehen haben dann sind
die aus deinem team man das nun mal
werkmärkte schießt einfach auf alles was
ich eben wie bewegung bist tot in 32
alter ich laufe seit zehn milliarden
jahren rum das ok chef kopf ich liebe
dich trotzdem muss ich nein
was soll das wieso gegen den messern
nicht ich hab doch messen immer auf die
mittlere maustaste gelegt wo ist denn
hier nahkampf was für pax mittlere
maustaste du vollidiot warte geht es
jetzt aber jetzt geht es natürlich
wieder scheiße das wäre mein job es soll
einfach nicht sein des chefkochs führt
ist einfach meine große die akten dazu
wird man das den gegner dessen gegner
und ich werde ich genau jetzt
wieder im team kamera rede jeden von
euch umbringen und dann ein kleines
stück technik dann heraus ich bin wieder
tod ja ja man das ist doch diese scheiße
immer ihre hecken alle alle man kann
nicht so krasse das macht er ja klar
kommen stets voraus und flugzeug alles
klappt damit das ganze jetzt mal ein
bisschen spannender zu geht bin ich eine
frau alle lobby dann das heißt ich werde
jetzt einfach rumlaufen und nicht man
ist quasi jeder gegen jeden das heißt
jeder kann mich umbringen ich kann jeden
umbringen und das ganze ist einfach von
17 schnellerer ich habe das dumpfe
gefühl dass in diesem haus jemand ist
aber es ist niemand in diesem haus also
hat mich meine türen kann ich nicht
irgendwie funktioniert nicht irgendwie
bin ich ganz alleine habe ich das gefühl
jetzt umgehen da die krassen kurz grad
losgelassen nein nein nein
ach man
komm her mein freitag 11 und ich bin
schon wieder
ach man das machen keinen spaß
ich hab dich gesehen der schock meines
lebens alter da steht auf einer neben
mir ein bier bilden
allerdings eine lampe abschießen oder
doch ich habe noch ein gemacht hätte das
jahr freunde wenn irgend einer von euch
hier action bildern kinder zu mir kommen
laut jada der denkt ja komm leichte
beute soll kann ich norden auf ich
glaube dass mit dem ersten platz wird
noch ein bisschen schwierig ach so
versteht ein geschütz rum alles klar
freunde wahrscheinlich ist es ein
geschäfts diese scheiß gestalter ich war
der letzte tod habe nicht rechts und
jetzt werde ich abgeschlossen
das täterduo ich bin vorletzter geworden
wenigstens nicht letzteres ist das sage
ich mir in jedem wettbewerb im leben
das war es mit black out dem ich bin ja
völlig überbelichtet wenn es euch
gefallen dann würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen ich denke ich werde nie
wieder zähle die auf einem kanal bringen
als einfach es war wirklich langweilig
oder hat es euch irgendwie gefallen und
sonst würd ich sagen sehen wir uns
morgen in anderen video wieder uns war
in einem sarg ich nicht schluss